10 juin 40, les troupes allemandes
ont passé la Somme.
Les armées françaises sont en déroute.
Déclarée ville ouverte,
Paris tombe le 14 juin.
L'avancée allemande est fulgurante.
Fuyant la terrible percée,
2 millions de Parisiens
prennent le chemin de l'exode.
Dans ces colonnes,
on retrouve une foule désordonnée,
refluant vers on ne sait où.
Des familles portant
leur enfant à bout de bras,
soutenant leurs vieillards.
Emportant les quelques valeurs
qu'elles ont pu rassembler.
L'arrivée des Allemands n'est cependant pas
une mauvaise nouvelle pour tout le monde.
Remontant à contre-courant
cette marée humaine,
trois hommes se dirigent vers la capitale.
Deux sont des espions allemands.
Le troisième est français.
Il s'appelle Henri Chamberlin.
C'est un repris de justice, un voyou.
Dans à peine un an,
sous le nom de Henri Lafont,
il sera l'un des chefs
de la Gestapo à Paris.
Une police d'un genre spécial
dans laquelle on retrouve,
les plus dangereux criminels de l'époque.
Arrestation de juifs et de patriotes.
Trafics.
Vols, tortures, assassinats.
Nous sommes en juin 1940,
la pègre a choisi son camp.
Henri Lafont,
le parrain de la Gestapo
Qui est Henri Lafont ? Il est né
en 1902 dans le 13ᵉ arrondissement à Paris.
C'est un pauvre gosse.
Il a une enfance malheureuse
qui le conduit,
assez inévitablement sur le chemin
de la petite délinquance.
Il est très rapidement repéré
évidemment par la police,
ce qui le conduit en colonie pénitentiaire
jusqu'à sa majorité.
Henri Lafont,
au moment de la débâcle
française, a 38 ans,
il a passé près de la moitié de sa vie
en colonie pénitentiaire ou en prison.
Et il est précisément incarcéré
au moment où intervient,
la chute de la République,
au moment où les armées allemandes
enfoncent le front français.
À ce moment là, il est en prison à Paris,
on soustrait l'ensemble des prisonniers,
à l'avance allemande en faisant
reculer ces prisonniers,
au fur et à mesure que les Allemands
progressent dans le territoire.
En juin 40, il est incarcéré
avec des espions allemands,
ce qu'on appelle la cinquième colonne,
des espions allemands infiltrés en France,
avec qui il va s'échapper.
Et c'est là que sa vie va changer.
Parce que lui qui n'était
à priori qu'un petit voleur,
un petit escroc condamné à la marginalité,
à subir une vie,
finalement sans relief.
Cette rencontre qu'il fait avec ces agents
allemands va radicalement changer la donne,
puisqu'il va remonter à Paris avec
ces agents qu'il va guider.
C'est l'enfant du territoire,
c'est le français qui va les aider,
à remonter vers la capitale pour rejoindre
les nouveaux maîtres de Paris.
Ces gens là vont lui présenter
leurs supérieurs.
C'est à partir de ce moment-là
qu'il va devenir un agent allemand.
La Gestapo,
c'est la police de sécurité du Reich,
qui va, au fil du temps,
assumer une fonction de police politique,
pourrait-on dire,
et cette police politique
va se charger de la répression,
de toutes les forces qui menacent
la sécurité intérieure du Reich.
Les Allemands ne sont pas assez nombreux
en France pour tenir ce pays sans avoir,
recours à des auxiliaires
recrutés localement.
C'est ce que Hitler a théorisé
dans Mein Kampf sous l'expression,
de participation indigène.
Ces relais, forcément, on va les trouver
chez des gens qui sont prêts à se vendre,
à devenir des traîtres, qui n'ont pas
d'autre patrie que celle de l'argent.
Et évidemment, les gens du milieu
correspondent assez bien à ce profil.
Ce ne sont pas des gens politisés,
ce sont des gens qui n'agissent
que pour eux ou pour leur groupe.
Ils vivent en marge de la société,
ils ne partagent pas le destin
de leurs concitoyens.
Déjà au départ, ils se positionnent
comme étant des ennemis de la société.
Évidemment, passer d'ennemi
de la société à traître,
finalement le pas est aisément franchissable
pour ces gens que la morale n'étouffe pas.
Il va travailler avec eux,
leur fait des propositions.
Sa proposition est assez simple,
il va servir de délateur, il va faire
de la provocation, de l'entrisme.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est qu'il
va proposer aux Allemands :
"Des petits truands,
j'en ai vu plein en prison.
Ce sont des gens qui ont des condamnations
à perpétuité ou très lourdes,
si vous leur donnez quelques pouvoirs,
et surtout la possibilité de faire
des bénéfices à gauche et à droite,
ce sont des gens qui vous serviront
extrêmement fidèlement."
Dès juillet 1940, ça fait un mois qu'il
s'est mis au service des Allemands.
Il se présente à la prison de Fresnes,
et il exige la libération
d'un certain nombre de prisonniers,
et de façon tout à fait extraordinaire,
c'est un paradoxe,
qui s'explique par l'esprit du temps.
L'administration pénitentiaire
ne va pas s'opposer à cette démarche,
qui n'est pas une démarche officielle,
qui n'est pas soutenue par les Allemands,
et qui se fait comme ça à l'amiable.
Lafont arrive à la prison de Fresnes,
il montre une carte de police, il est
accompagné de 2 sous-officiers allemands,
et il exige qu'on libère des prisonniers.
Parmi ces 30 prisonniers,
on a essentiellement des lâches,
des gens qui forment ce qu'on peut
appeler la base de la basse pègre,
des gens qui sont des petits escrocs,
mais qui sont très intéressants.
Ces gens, une fois éparpillés dans Paris,
vont pouvoir ramener au chef,
à celui qui se pose désormais
comme étant le chef, Henri Lafont,
toutes sortes d'affaires et puis ils vont
être ses oreilles, ses yeux,
dans les bars, ils vont pouvoir
faire remonter les informations.
Jean Rossi, proxénète, racketteur
Cazauba, dit "Daix",
Patron de bars, faussaire, proxénète
Chave, dit "nez de braise",
cambrioleur, trafiquant
Estebeteguy, dit le "Le basque"
Proxénète, recéleur, cambrioleur
Pour pouvoir devenir ce que les Allemands
appellent un V-Mann, un homme de confiance,
il faut évidemment faire la preuve
de son attachement à la cause n****.
Lafont n'est pas un n***,
c'est juste un opportuniste.
Mais s'il veut pouvoir profiter
des largesses allemandes,
il faut bien qu'il montre qu'il est
engagé dans cette guerre à leurs côtés.
On est juste après l'épisode
de la libération de Fresnes.
Les hauts gradés allemands de la capitale
ont assez mal pris cet épisode,
parce que Lafont encore une fois
n'avait pas été mandaté pour cela.
On est face à l'armée allemande,
des officiers dans la tradition prussienne,
respectueux d'un certain ordre
et Lafont à ce moment là, en juillet 40,
est au bord de se faire arrêter
et Lafont apprend,
que les Allemands aimeraient
bien mettre la main,
sur un responsable des services
de renseignement belges, Lambrecht,
qui s'est réfugié en France en zone libre,
hors de leur portée.
Adrien Estebeteguy, dit "Le Basque",
qu'il a libéré,
qui a vécu longtemps à Bordeaux
et qui a de grosses connexions à Toulouse.
Toulouse, qui est précisément la ville
où s'est réfugié Lambrecht,
L'histoire paraît invraisemblable.
Lafont fait un raid, tout simplement.
Il prend sa voiture,
il se rend à Toulouse,
il apprend par des membres
du milieu local,
où se cache Lambrecht. Il frappe
à sa porte et il l'assomme,
il le met dans son coffre
et remonte à Paris avec.
C'est aussi simple que ça.
C'est stupéfiant.
Mais les choses semblent bien s'être
passé de cette manière là.
Pour les Allemands, l'effet est exactement
celui qu'on peut ressentir,
en écoutant cette histoire.
Ils n'en reviennent pas.
Cette arrestation de Lambrecht a 2 conséquences.
La première pour Lafont,
qui sans doute,
devient un personnage intéressant
aux yeux de la haute hiérarchie allemande,
qui se disent tiens, on a quand même
quelqu'un qui est pratique, sous la main.
Et surtout, la conséquence la plus
dramatique, c'est évidemment pour Lambrecht,
et pour les services
de renseignements belges.
Lambrecht va être maltraité
et va être déporté,
et son arrestation va amener
l'arrestation de plusieurs dizaines,
voire centaines de membres des réseaux belges
de renseignement à travers l'Europe.
On voit la nocivité d'un homme comme Lafont
à travers cette histoire dramatique.
On voit qu'un homme
peut faire ce mal là.
Ici France Actualités !
Les nouvelles de toute
la France et de l'Empire.
Autour du maréchal Pétain.
Le Pays se retrouve.
Retrouve avec l'esprit nouveau,
son sens oublié, la tradition perdue,
la continuité de son histoire.
Et quand, devant le chef, les milliers de
légionnaires lèveront la main pour ce serment,
dont la simplicité double la grandeur.
Quand d'innombrables voix diront : "Nous jurons
de continuer à servir la France et le chef".
c'est Pétain qui dira,
acceptant une nouvelle fois,
la lourde charge
qu'il porte sans faiblesse :
"J'en renouvelle le serment
moi-même avec vous."
Les grandes déclarations, les serments
masquent une pénible réalité.
À l'ombre des anciens héros,
un nouveau système s'épanouit.
Les places sont libres pour
qui accepte de collaborer.
Le milieu français s'apprête à vivre
quelques unes de ses plus belles années.
Pour Lafont et ses complices,
c'est le temps de la puissance,
c'est le temps de l'impunité.
Les Allemands se comportent,
certes, extrêmement durement,
mais tous ces gens ou ces chefs sont
pratiquement docteur en droit, en philosophie...
Ils ont une espèce de respect insensé,
jusqu'à l'écœurement du droit,
et donc on ne peut
pas faire n'importe quoi.
Les mauvais coups des attentats
contre les synagogues, des assassinats...
De l'entrisme
dans les réseaux de résistance,
on va charger des officines parallèles.
Voilà comment la Gestapo de la rue Lauriston
s'est mise en place
et elle diffère de toutes
les autres Gestapo,
non pas tant par sa violence,
non pas tant par l'appât du gain,
non pas tant par la crapulerie,
des gens qui la constituaient,
mais par le fait que,
à la tête de cette officine
93, rue Lauriston,
il y a un truand, Chamberlin, donc Lafont,
et puis un policier.
Et pas n'importe quel policier,
il s'appelle Bonny.
Et ce Bonny a été, au moment
de l'affaire Stavisky,
on l'a traité de premier
policier de France.
1934, l'escroc Alexandre Stavisky
détourne 200 millions de francs,
du Crédit Municipal de Bayonne.
Le scandale dégénère en affaire d'État
et le 6 février,
les ligues fascistes
marchent sur l'Assemblée.
C'est l'inspecteur Bonny qui,
en réunissant des preuves,
permet de faire progresser l'enquête
et de calmer les esprits.
Pour ce dernier,
ce fut un moment de gloire.
Bonny est corrompu, il en existe
quelques-uns dans la police.
Il a été révoqué et il a monté,
comme la plupart
de ses collègues révoqués,
une officine de police privée spécialisée
dans la provocation,
le divorce, l'adultère...
Et pour lui, c'est son bâton de maréchal
et c'est un bon flic, Bonny.
Il est corrompu
mais c'est un bon policier.
Et il va apporter à la Gestapo
de la rue Lauriston,
une efficacité qu'aucune
des autres Gestapo n'aura.
Les Allemands ont un plan.
Quand ils présentent Lafont à Bonny,
ils ont un plan.
L'idée, c'est d'associer d'un côté
l'instinct du prédateur, de Lafont, le voyou,
le voyou qui a des connexions
dans le milieu,
qui a montré son allégeance
aux nouveaux maîtres de Paris,
et de l'autre côté la rigueur
de l'administrateur, de l'enquêteur.
Bonny, c'est l'homme
qui va créer des dossiers,
qui va créer un fichier alphanumérique,
qui va s'occuper de toute l'intendance
de la maison rue Lauriston.
C'est lui qui va s'occuper de la caisse
de la trésorerie de la rue Lauriston.
C'est l'homme aussi qui va participer
aux interrogatoires.
Il sait très bien interroger,
il a été formé pour ça.
Cette rencontre entre Bonny et Lafont
est voulue, soutenue,
et encouragée par les Allemands,
à tel point qu'ils vont former un binôme.
Ils rentrent d'ailleurs dans la postérité
sous le nom de groupe Bonny-Lafont.
La Gestapo rue Lauriston, dite Carlingue,
est aussi appelée le groupe Bonny-Lafont,
même si Bonny n'est que le second de Lafont
et ne sera jamais que le second de Lafont.
Le recrutement des membres
de la bande de la rue Lauriston,
ne va pas cesser
tout au long de la période,
Lafont va recruter tous
les talents qui viennent à lui.
On observe une montée en puissance.
Il recrute des gens de plus en plus menaçants,
inquiétant, des vrais
ennemis de la société,
au sens qu'on donnait alors
à cette expression.
Il faut en citer quelques-uns.
Abel Danos dit le "mammouth",
Le bel Abel, Bibil, Buffalo Bill.
Ses surnoms en disent quelque chose.
Le mammouth, c'est un costaud.
Buffalo Bill, il tire à tout va.
il est toujours armé.
Une note de police le présente,
comme extrêmement dangereux,
toujours armé.
Ne pas l'appréhender, attendre les renforts.
C'est quelqu'un de très dangereux
et c'est une légende déjà dans le milieu.
C'est un ami intime de Pierre Loutrel,
qui va entrer dans l'histoire du grand
banditisme sous le surnom de "Pierrot le Fou".
Il connaît Jo Attia,
le futur roi du non-lieu.
Il connaît intimement Georges Boucheseiche,
dit le gros Joe.
C'est un ami, évidemment, d'Émile Buisson,
dit l'insaisissable,
qui va devenir l'ennemi public numéro un.
Avec Abel Danos, on est tout de suite
dans la très haute voyoucratie,
et on est immédiatement
dans cette crème du milieu.
Un autre personnage très important
qui va rentrer rue Lauriston,
c'est un personnage absolument considérable
qui s'appelle Jean Sartol, dit Jean le Chauve,
qui est considéré par le rapport de police
de l'époque comme étant un seigneur du milieu.
C'est-à-dire que cet homme a atteint
un statut dans le milieu,
qui fait de lui l'un de ses chefs.
Il est considéré comme l'un
des 10 plus grands voyous de son époque.
Jean Sartol, va bien évidemment,
comme l'ensemble des voyous,
apprendre que rue Lauriston,
il se passe quelque chose,
qu'il y a un chef
qui peut arranger les choses,
et il va se mettre
au service de cette structure,
pour tout simplement pouvoir
développer ses propres trafics,
en reversant bien entendu,
l'impôt qu'on doit au chef,
qu'il doit à Lafont.
Le lendemain,
je l'ai retrouvé rue Lauriston.
- C'est lui !
- Qui lui ?
- En uniforme.
- Il est Allemand ?
- Non, il s'habille comme ça pour
impressionner l'adversaire.
- Je passe l'éponge.
Tu viens avec l'argent, on efface tout.
Regarde-moi quand je te parle !
- Si t'essaies encore de me doubler...
- Merci, patron mais c'est...
Un malentendu, je sais. Ta g**** !
Passe à la caisse dans la semaine,
sinon c'est toi qu'on efface. Dégage !
- Il est bien luné, on y va.
Patron, pardon, je voudrais
vous présenter un très bon copain,
Léon Jabinet. Léo pour les dames.
On a partagé la même cellule à Fresnes,
il n'y a pas si longtemps.
T'étais tombé pour quoi ?
C'est un violent,
on ne dirait pas comme ça !
En plus, il est un peu fêlé.
Présentement, il est dans la misère.
- Tu connais le tarif, c'est 40 000 !
Alors qu'est-ce que c'est qu'être
un gestapiste de la rue Lauriston ?
Ça veut dire d'abord avoir,
ce qu'on appelle dans l'argot du milieu,
le carton.
C'est un Ausweis, très particulier,
sur lequel il est écrit
que le possesseur de cette carte,
ne doit en aucun cas être inquiété
non seulement par les Allemands,
les autorités allemandes...
Mais qu'il peut même
les réquisitionner à sa demande,
C'est-à-dire qu'il peut
obtenir l'aide des Allemands,
qu'ils soient policiers, soldats ou autre.
C'est, deuxièmement, la possibilité
dans un pays où il n'y en a plus.
Même la gendarmerie allemande,
des fois en manque,
il n'y a plus d'essence, d'avoir des voitures
et de l'essence sans problème.
Et puis c'est la possibilité
d'avoir des armes.
Des armes modernes,
pistolets mitrailleurs Schmeisser,
quand ce n'est pas des Beretta.
En face, on a les policiers officiels.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Ils n'ont plus d'essence pour leurs voitures.
Ils sont armés de 6.35,
Le Français ou Manufrance,
avec une portée de 10 mètres.
Et puis ils sont comme tous les Français,
ils sont pétris de craintes,
quand ce n'est pas
de terreur face à des gens,
qui disent même avec un accent corse.
Police allemande. Gestapo.
Désormais, ils pourront aller cambrioler.
Ce sera une perquisition.
Ils pourront aller voler.
Ce sera une saisie.
Ils pourront aller racketter,
ce sera tout simplement une mise
à l'amende quasiment officielle,
comme si un procès-verbal avait été établi.
On est là dans une inversion des valeurs,
qui correspond plus généralement
aux temps de guerre,
le moment d'un affaissement moral.
De l'Océan Glacial Arctique
jusqu'à la mer Noire,
soit sur un fond de près de 3000 km,
les forces allemandes ont pris position.
La lutte pour la défense
de l'Occident est engagée.
La plus grande offensive qui n'a jamais été
menée au cours de l'histoire a commencé.
Bientôt, malgré la résistance des
160 divisions de l'Armée rouge,
les frontières sont basées
sur tous les points.
En France aussi, la guerre continue.
Une guerre secrète dans laquelle
les traîtres sont à l'honneur.
Pour Lafont, c'est le temps du triomphe.
Dominateur, il sait se faire obéir,
craindre et respecter.
Son audace et son charisme,
vont lui permettre
de se rapprocher du pouvoir.
Lafont, ce petit truand devient l'un des
personnages les plus influents de France.
car il a des connexions avec
les plus hauts gradés allemands.
Lafont devient quelqu'un d'important.
C'est une revanche formidable pour lui.
Lui qui a connu
une vie assez misérable jusqu'en 40,
devient un homme que
les puissants veulent connaître.
C'est tout à fait incroyable quand on
y pense. Il fréquente Laval. Laval le tutoie.
Il fréquente Bousquet,
le secrétaire général de la police,
il fréquente Amédée Bussière,
le préfet de police.
Et tous ces gens,
pourquoi fréquentent-ils Lafont ?
Parfois c'est trivial,
c'est parce que Lafont,
peut leur trouver de la nourriture,
c'est aussi simple que ça.
Par exemple, Karl Bömelburg,
le chef de la Gestapo en France,
passe par Lafont pour se nourrir.
Knochen accepte des cadeaux de Lafont.
Knochen qui est quand même le numéro 2
de la police de sécurité allemande en France,
l'un des personnages les plus puissants
sur notre territoire à cette époque là.
Il se fait livrer régulièrement des cadeaux,
il reçoit un peu d'argent en liquide...
Laval vient à lui pour obtenir la libération
de deux personnes, c'est avéré.
Parce que le but ultime de Lafont est
de se dégager de la tutelle allemande.
D'être le plus indépendant
possible dans son activité,
en rendant des services
et en démontrant sa puissance,
même si elle n'est que provisoire, il montre
l'intérêt qu'il y a à le connaître,
et l'intérêt à le laisser
dans cette position là.
On est dans un moment de l'histoire de France,
dans ce basculement là,
qui autorise ces rapprochements là,
qui autorise qu'un malfrat,
tutoie le président du Conseil,
c'est lamentable,
mais c'est évidemment l'une
des leçons aussi de cette période.
On assiste à une inversion
totale des valeurs.
Les valeurs, où sont-elles dans tout ça ?
Il faut dépeindre ce système.
L'armistice qui a été signé par
les autorités françaises et allemandes
prévoyait que la France livre
un certain nombre de marchandises.
Il y avait des quotas qui étaient fixés
et que par ailleurs,
la France paie,
au titre des frais d'occupation,
des sommes absolument extravagantes,
anormalement extravagantes,
qui ne correspondaient
à aucune réalité économique,
puisque la France devait payer
20 millions de reichsmark par jour,
au titre des frais d'occupation. 20 millions
de reichsmark, c'est 400 millions de francs.
Les Allemands vont très vite être
tentés de spéculer sur cet argent,
en le réinjectant dans les canaux
économiques français pour obtenir en échange,
des marchandises qui vont lui permettre,
qui vont permettre à l'Allemagne,
de faire marcher à plein régime son économie
de guerre, puisqu'on est dans une guerre totale.
Pour cela, ils doivent trouver les stocks
et ils doivent aussi,
proposer des tarifs attrayants
pour que les vendeurs viennent à eux,
et leur proposent leurs marchandises.
Le marché noir qu'on décrit
et que les Allemands eux mêmes combattaient,
ils en sont quasiment les instigateurs.
Les Allemands vont utiliser
ces circuits parallèles,
grâce aux sommes considérables
dont ils disposent,
pour s'emparer des richesses nationales.
Richesses nationales qui vont
des métaux non ferreux au vin.
Et dans cette galaxie, vous allez avoir
ce qu'on appelle des bureaux d'achat,
qui ont une existence semi officielle,
qui sont alimentés par ces ressources,
parfois officielles,
parfois qui ne le sont pas,
et qui permettent à l'Allemagne d'acheter
énormément sur le marché français,
ce qui garantit également aux intermédiaires
des marges très juteuses.
En intervenant dans ces processus,
les agents de la Gestapo française
vont se révéler d'excellents commerçants.
Des intermédiaires inquiétants
prêts à tous les mauvais coups,
des prédateurs voraces à l'affût
des bonnes occasions.
Pour eux, c'est le temps des affaires,
des marchés douteux,
et de l'argent facile.
Le rôle confié au groupe Bonny-Lafont,
ça va être d'abord
de sécuriser ces transactions,
parce qu'on est là dans un
univers un peu gris, plein de trafiquants,
qui peuvent être tentés d'escroquer
les autorités d'occupation.
Dans un second temps, leur action va
s'orienter vers le commerce en tant que tel,
on va leur demander d'aller
à la recherche des stocks,
et de trouver les stocks et de s'intercaler
en tant qu'intermédiaire dans ces trafics.
Entre un vendeur qui parfois
ne souhaite pas vendre,
mais Lafont est convaincant.
Un vendeur et puis l'acheteur final,
qui sont les autorités d'occupation.
Ce sont des trafics très simples
car dans les bureaux d'achat,
on ne demande rien au vendeur, ni son
identité, ni l'origine des marchandises.
Donc on imagine toute la faune qui
est attirée par un trafic aussi simple.
Pas de mise de fonds, pas de stock.
C'est la recette de la fortune.
En cette fin d'année, des âmes
charitables songent aux déshérités,
et dans le quartier des Halles,
une soupe gratuite leur est distribuée.
Ici, ceux qui ont faim trouveront
un repas substantiel,
et aussi un peu de réconfort moral.
À cette époque-là, les queues s'allongent
devant les magasins. Les biens se font rares.
L'alimentation est compliquée à obtenir.
Les Français doivent passer par
le marché noir et dans le même temps,
ces Gestapo constituent des îlots de prospérité.
Au milieu de cette misère, ces groupes
de Français qui travaillent pour les Allemands,
et évidemment au premier chef,
le groupe de la rue Lauriston.
vit dans une opulence formidable.
C'est une époque absolument
merveilleuse pour ces gens là.
Ils font un festin pendant
que les autres meurt de faim.
Rue Lauriston, on fait fête sur fête.
Le champagne coule.
On est vraiment là,
dans une idée de rattrapage.
Ces gens qui étaient des voyous,
des proscrits, des relégables,
des condamnés à la marginalité,
finalement d'un seul coup,
font à peu près tout ce qu'ils veulent.
Lafont, multiplie les aventures,
a des aventures avec certaines des plus
belles femmes de Paris à l'époque,
quelques mannequins, notamment
de chez Schiaparelli ou Chanel.
On retrouve aussi des starlettes
dans l'entourage de Corinne Luchaire,
qui amène des starlettes
avec elles rue Lauriston.
Les artistes vont s'encanailler
rue Lauriston. On fait des banquets.
Tino Rossi vient.
Ça ne fait pas de lui un collaborateur,
mais quelqu'un qui participe
très légèrement et sans doute,
sans pleinement prendre conscience
de la gravité des choses,
ou de la dangerosité des gens qu'il
fréquente, mais qui participe,
de ce système de fêtes perpétuelles.
Les cabarets sont ouverts, fonctionnent
très bien sous l'occupation,
ils sont réservés à une certaine clientèle qui
est celle des collabos ou des officiers allemands.
Les maisons closes tournent
aussi à plein régime.
Lafont et ses hommes les fréquentent,
quand ils n'en sont pas
les propriétaires clandestinement.
Les cabarets de Pigalle et Montmartre
passent sous la coupe de Lafont.
Ces années sont, pour ces hommes
de la rue Lauriston,
des années qui peuvent se résumer de la
manière suivante : Le soir, on fait la fête,
on s'amuse et le jour, on vend
des marchandises ou des hommes aux Allemands.
Il faut quand même prendre conscience
de l'importance de ces activités.
JeanSartol, le truand
dit "Jean le Chauve",
a reconnu après-guerre à avoir
participé au pillage,
de plus de 1000 appartements,
1000 appartements en trois ans.
On est à quasiment un appartement
par jour, dimanche compris.
Cet homme va fêter
son 100ᵉ million de francs en 43,
il va faire une grande fête
où il invite tous ses amis des Gestapo,
et quelques gradés allemands pour fêter
son 100ᵉ million de francs collectés.
Là, on prend quand même conscience des
fortunes qui sont réalisées et de l'impunité,
dans laquelle ces fortunes sont réalisées
alors qu'elles sont, à l'évidence,
totalement d'origine illégale,
même pas illégale, immorale.
Et évidemment, pour pouvoir
faire du commerce avec les Allemands,
il faut aussi faire
de la répression pour leurs services.
Et donc il y a une sorte d'équilibre,
qui va se trouver dans les Gestapo
françaises et évidemment rue Lauriston,
entre les affaires commerciales et
la répression et parfois tout se mélange.
On peut faire des affaires commerciales
et de la répression.
Quand on va arrêter
des agents alliés parachutés,
généralement, ils ont de grosses
sommes d'argent sur eux.
On les récupère à ce moment là.
Quand on va intervenir chez un riche juif
dans le cadre de la politique antisémite,
suivie par l'occupant à l'époque, tout est pris
dans la maison jusqu'aux prises de courant.
Ce système se tient bien.
Il est d'une grande efficacité.
Parce que ces agents
ne leur coûtent finalement rien.
Ils ont des dizaines de Français à leur
service dans les Gestapo française,
qui ne leur coûtent pas un sou.
Ces agents se nourrissent sur la bête.
Quand ils arrêtent quelqu'un,
ils le dépouillent, ce sont des loups.
Et ces loups, les Allemands,
leur mettent une laisse,
ils en font des chiens de garde.
Cette meute va traquer les résistants,
harceler les juifs.
Les truands deviennent policiers.
D'étranges policiers qui interviennent
hors de tout contrôle.
Intimidation, abus de pouvoir, violence.
C'est le temps de la répression.
La torture a toujours été utilisée
comme un moyen, rue Lauriston,
pour forcer les gens à arrêter à parler,
c'était une torture qui n'était
pas particulièrement élaborée.
Il s'agissait de tabassages à coups
de matraques, à coups de poings, ou de pieds,
ou de bastonnades.
Parfois, le supplice de l'eau était utilisé,
on prenait le prisonnier,
on le plongeait dans une baignoire,
en général remplie
d'une eau saturée d'immondices.
Ça fait partie aussi du processus
d'humiliation des victimes,
et on le plongeait dans l'eau
jusqu'à suffocation.
C'est extrêmement éprouvant
pour la personne qui en est victime.
Et en général, les évanouissements
arrivaient très fréquemment,
et pour réveiller les prisonniers,
on leur glissait entre les dents,
un mélange de savon et d'essence.
Devant mon obstination à ne pas avouer,
j'ai été conduit à la salle de bain.
Pendant 1h30, ils me torturèrent
Ma déposition ayant été jugée insuffisante,
ils me firent subir une seconde
séance le lendemain matin.
On est dans un schéma de torture qui
qui se multiplie une nouvelle fois,
et qui atteint des paroxysmes,
qui sont terrifiants, extrêmement choquants.
Certains prisonniers français ont expliqué,
après avoir été arrêtés par les hommes
de Lafont et avoir été ensuite,
remis aux autorités allemandes, qu'ils
étaient mieux traités par les Allemands,
que par les Français de la Gestapo.
Un des phénomènes de la torture, c'est
d'abord cette espèce d'avilissement de l'être,
que cherchait la Gestapo.
Au départ, ils voulaient obtenir des aveux,
parce qu'ils étaient extrêmement
formalistes et pointilleux.
Il leur fallait des aveux écrits,
enregistrés, notés,
et ensuite la justice expéditive
pouvait passer, mais seulement,
après des aveux,
des aveux, n'importe quoi.
Que l'on veuille torturer
pour obtenir des renseignements,
mais je crois que dans le cas
de la Gestapo, c'était bien pire,
c'était une espèce de volonté
sadique de faire du mal.
La rue Lauriston a excellé dans la lutte
contre les réseaux français.
Alors, on introduit, on fait
de l'entrisme dans ces réseaux,
et des gens qui vont évidemment
trahir l'organisation qu'ils ont pénétré.
Pour prendre des réseaux très connus,
Alliance a subi plus de 400 arrestations.
Marco Polo, qui est un groupe de résistance,
c'est de la résistance très liée à Londres.
Tombe plusieurs fois, trois fois
l'état major de Marco Polo,
défense de la France et également,
subi des arrestations et des chutes énormes,
dont la plus emblématique Geneviève de Gaulle,
qui est d'ailleurs arrêtée
par Bonny lui-même.
Les Allemands ont toujours été très vigilants
par rapport aux questions de propagande.
C'est parce qu'ils prennent
la presse clandestine au sérieux,
que "Défense de la France", qui est
l'un des journaux les plus importants,
de la France captive,
est dans leur ligne de mire.
Vous allez avoir une traque policière,
c'est-à-dire que des individus vont être
arrêtés soit à leur domicile,
soit sur leur lieu de travail.
Des hommes de la bande Bonny-Lafont
vont être postés rue Bonaparte,
dans une librairie qui s'appelle
Aux vœux de Louis XII,
librairie qui est la boite aux lettres
principale du mouvement de résistance,
c'est-à-dire là où ils déposent
et reçoivent des consignes...
J'avais des petits papiers
dans une enveloppe à déposer.
Je vais prendre la bicyclette de mon père.
Je pars tranquillement, je pose
ma bicyclette à deux pas de la librairie,
et puis je me dis : "C'est drôle,
la porte n'est pas fermée comme d'habitude."
Je ne sais plus exactement
quels détails et je me suis dit :
"Est-ce qu'il faut entrer ou pas ?"
Si on a peur parce qu'une porte
est comme ci ou comme ça,
ce n'est pas la peine de vouloir
continuer à faire des choses par ci par là.
Il vaut mieux s'arrêter et comme tu n'es pas
partie pour t'arrêter, alors il faut le faire.
J'ouvre la porte et il y a quelqu'un
qui me saute dessus.
Je ne sais pas si c'était Bonny ou Lafont,
mais il y avait 2 hommes qui étaient là,
et qui m'emmènent directement
dans l'arrière-boutique.
Quel est le bilan de cette opération ?
Une cinquantaine de membres sont arrêtés,
25 sont arrêtés aux vœux de Louis XII
et l'autre moitié,
sur leur lieu de travail ou à leur domicile.
J'ai passé la nuit du 20 juillet 1943
en prison à Fresnes,
et je n'en suis sorti
que vers le 20 janvier 44.
Et là, de partir en train pour
arriver directement à Grunwald,
et pour partir
à un autre endroit en Autriche.
Mes chers amis, pour la quatrième fois,
la France célèbre
dans l'épreuve et la tristesse,
un Noël de guerre.
Noël, Fête de la Nativité.
Et la mort plane sur le monde entier.
Et la France subit chaque jour
l'épreuve cruelle,
de nouveaux crimes
et l'immense misère des bombardements.
Malgré tant de désastres,
je garde ma foi
dans l'avenir de la France.
Une fois de plus, je vous demande
de penser par dessus tout,
au péril de mort que courrait notre pays,
si sur lui s'abattait
la hideuse guerre civile.
Les incantations n'y feront rien.
Le vent mauvais redouté par Pétain souffle
chaque jour plus fort sur la France.
Les maquis enflent.
La résistance se développe.
Lafont, le vautour s'imagine
à présent en aigle.
Le voyou se rêve général.
Fin 43 le système du bureau d'achat perd
son efficacité, perd son sens,
devient moins rentable pour les Allemands.
On observe un basculement.
Beaucoup de ces accrédités
qui jusqu'à présent,
étaient tantôt dans de la répression,
tantôt dans du commercial,
vont basculer vers une activité
plus spécifiquement répressive,
c'est-à-dire mener très concrètement des
assauts contre des mouvements de résistance.
- Colonel Knochen, notre ami Lafont,
qui a l'énergie et l'expérience
propre à vaincre,
dans ce genre de lutte,
propose de mettre sur pied,
une brigade composée d'ex-tirailleurs
nord africains.
Équipés et entraînés,
avec pour mission ramener le calme
et l'ordre dans les campagnes.
- Notre seul objectif, c'est la libre
circulation de nos troupes,
afin de permettre le prélèvement de ce
qui est nécessaire à notre intendance et...
aux besoins du peuple allemand.
Cher ami Lafont,
Si dans, disons trois mois,
l'exercice n'est pas sûr,
nous appliquerons aux paysans français
le régime que nous appliquons,
aux moujiks en Russie.
Et ça, c'est clair ?
Tout à fait, colonel.
Allez bois un coup, c'est du bon.
Ne te casse pas la tête avec ça,
je vais m'en occuper.
Lafont a pris goût au pouvoir.
Il est un chef de service
de police respecté, craint.
Il a une autre ambition.
Il a l'ambition de devenir un chef de guerre.
Il a une grande idée
à la fin de l'année 43,
il a l'idée de mobiliser
ou plutôt d'incorporer,
les prisonniers nord africains que les
Allemands détiennent depuis 1940,
dans un corps d'armée,
il a carrément cette ambition.
Et évidemment, les Allemands ne peuvent
finalement accueillir que favorablement,
l'idée d'une troupe qui viendrait
sécuriser les arrières de leur front.
Il s'agit d'une population pauvre,
peu éduquée,
qui est constituée essentiellement
de manœuvres, de journaliers,
de garçons de bars.
On trouve parmi eux quelques souteneurs,
quelques délinquants.
On trouve aussi quelques assassins.
On comprend bien pourquoi ils s'engagent,
dans la brigade nord africaine,
c'est d'abord et surtout,
pour avoir eux-aussi une carte et être
à l'abri des investigations de la police.
Et à cette occasion là, ils rejoignent l'Ordre
Noir et ils deviennent des militaires SS.
À cette occasion, Lafont obtient
le grade de capitaine,
Bonny et les cinq chefs de section
deviennent des lieutenants.
Pour les gestapistes de la rue Lauriston,
avec le temps des défaites du Reich
vient celui de la répression.
Une répression sauvage, sans limites.
Ils porteront le feu dans les provinces
frondeuse. Ils brutaliseront.
Ils pilleront. Ils violeront.
C'est le temps des massacres.
On va essentiellement parler de son
activité en Corrèze et en Dordogne,
qui au départ était une activité
de pacification de la zone,
va rentrer dans une logique de terreur.
À défaut d'attaquer les maquis,
ils vont essayer de pacifier,
la région par la terreur. À chaque fois qu'ils
vont intervenir, ils feront de la même manière.
Menaçant, volant, pillant et violant,
le cas échéant aussi.
Il y a beaucoup de viols, évidemment.
Il y a une horde sauvage
qui s'abat sur cette région.
Ils avaient arrêté la mère,
ils ont fait une perquisiton chez ma soeur,
je ne les ai pas revus depuis.
Ils se vautrent littéralement
sur les populations civiles,
et sur les gens qu'ils arrêtent.
Ils menacent les pères de famille,
s'ils ne leur donnent pas leurs économies,
toute la famille va être déportée,
et ils en ont le pouvoir.
On est face à des populations démunies,
sans aucune protection face à eux.
Il y a le cas par exemple à Tulle,
avec Monange et un autre membre
de la brigade nord africaine.
qui agresse un jeune homme
dans la rue pour rien.
Le jeune homme passait,
Ils veulent l'arrêter,
ils sont tous les deux ivres,
et le jeune homme résiste, il ne veut
pas donner son bras pour se faire arrêter.
Il se fait tabasser très sévèrement,
avant de prendre une décharge
de fusil mitrailleur dans les jambes,
Ils veulent l'obliger à se relever
et ce malheureux ne peut pas se relever,
il se fait encore tabasser,
il va finir handicapé à vie, pour rien !
Ce jeune homme n'était pas un résistant.
On suit le chemin
de la brigade nord-africaine.
Un chemin qui est jalonné de sang,
de cris, de peur et qui
pèse lourd à la sortie,
puisqu'on voit qu'on a
plus de 100 victimes,
d'exécutions sommaires faites par les gens
de la brigade nord-africaine.
Ici France Actualité, nuit du lundi 5
au mardi 6 juin 1944, nuit historique.
Les anglo-américains débarquent
sur le sol de Normandie.
Dans la nuit, des tonnes d'acier
s'abattent sur les navires,
où pilonnent les défenses allemandes.
Les unités légères
prennent pied sur le rivage.
Et voici l'aube, au large,
l'impressionnante flotte anglo-américaine.
Le 13 août 1944, les derniers éléments
de la brigade rentrent à Paris.
Il faut dire que la plupart étaient
déjà rentrés. Lafont était déjà rentré,
écœuré d'ailleurs,
écœuré pas tant par
l'activité de ces hommes,
mais davantage par le sentiment
de plus en plus clair,
que la partie était perdue.
"Les bombardiers, à leur tour, déchaînent
l'attaque la plus massive,
que n'a jamais préparé
une opération militaire.
Les villes, le pays entier sont "coventrisés",
comme disaient les Allemands,
car il ne faut jamais oublier
que ce sont eux qui ont commencé.
Eux qui se vantaient de tout détruire
quand ils se croyaient les plus forts."
Lafont et Bonny vont tenter de s'enfuir.
Leur idée première,
c'est de rejoindre l'Espagne.
Malheureusement pour lui,
il part avec Bonny et leurs enfants.
Et il va vivre ce qu'il a
fait vivre aux autres.
Il va tomber sur un barrage qui
évidemment va lui confisquer sa voiture,
et il va demander au fils
de Pierre Bonny, Jacques Bonny,
de rentrer à Paris en vélo pour
demander de l'aide à un ami à eux,
à quelqu'un qu'ils croient
être un ami à eux,
un trafiquant notoire
qui s'appelle Joseph Joanovici,
un personnage très ambigu, très complexe,
résistant par ailleurs, mais pas vraiment,
un personnage tout en gris.
Et Joseph Joanovici,
va balancer ses anciens amis,
Lafont et Bonny
et la préfecture de police,
va envoyer des hommes pour les cueillir.
On est en septembre 1944.
Le procès Lafont va s'ouvrir très
rapidement puisque dès décembre 1944,
l'ensemble des membres de la rue Lauriston
qui ont été arrêtés,
vont être conduits devant le tribunal.
On est quand même juste 3 mois
après leur arrestation.
On est dans une instruction
qui a été faite dans un temps record,
trop rapide et ça a énervé les forces
de police qui s'occupaient de l'enquête.
On sent qu'il y a eu sur
cette affaire une pression,
notamment très particulière
des services de renseignement français.
Et l'opinion publique exigeait des têtes.
Il fallait tuer les traîtres et là,
on avait les traîtres parfaits.
Ils passent donc en jugement
et sont tous exécutés.
Ils sont 9 à être conduits au peloton
d'exécution, un matin de décembre 1944,
fin de la rue Lauriston.
Exécution de ces meneurs.
Les Français exécutent des traîtres
Au palais de justice à Paris,
2 traîtres ont été condamnés à mort pour
avoir prêté aux Allemands une aide ignoble.
Lafont et Bonny que vous voyez
en uniforme allemand.
Les traîtres ont été condamnés à être
fusillés par un peloton d'exécution,
composé de F.F.I.
Quelle erreur d'avoir fusillé ces gens
si vite alors qu'ils avaient,
tant de choses à nous dire !
Ils ont été fusillés dès décembre 44,
vous imaginez,
la guerre va encore durer 7 mois.
Je dirai que peut être on
les a fusillés d'autant plus vite,
qu'on avait pas trop envie
qu'ils racontent des choses.
Il y aurait peut-être
eu des mensonges, bien sûr,
mais je pense qu'ils savaient
quand même un certain nombre de choses,
Un certain nombre de personnalités qui...
Auront des rôles politiques ou
autres sous la quatrième République,
et ne sont pas tout à fait innocents,
vis-à-vis, de Lafont et de la Gestapo
de la rue Lauriston.
Quant à la... Pas la piétaille parce que
c'était des types impressionnants,
qui ont des meurtres
et des tortures sur la conscience,
des chutes de réseaux
de résistance ou autres,
beaucoup se sont recyclés après-guerre.
Le passage de la guerre
à l'après-guerre, pour eux,
s'est fait par le biais de la résistance.
Un grand nombre qui avait pressenti,
et qui avaient été embauchés
par des réseaux de résistance,
pour leur spécialité professionnelle,
notamment l'exécution en plein air public
au milieu des gens,
ça ne s'improvise pas.
On avait besoin de tueurs,
on a embauché des tueurs.
Un certain nombre, grâce à ce biais
de passage par la résistance,
vont échapper à la police et à la justice
d'une certaine manière,
et ce qui est très intéressant,
c'est de voir que ces gens là,
ont pris des habitudes d'impunité,
d'argent, de grosses voitures,
d'efficacité, de maniement d'armes
qui sont quand même des armes de guerre,
et ce sont eux qui vont constituer
le milieu des années d'après-guerre.
On peut difficilement ne pas citer
le cas d'Auguste Ricord,
qui sera bientôt connu dans le milieu
international, cette fois-ci,
sous le surnom de El Viejo, le vieux.
Quel est son rôle pendant l'occupation
aux côtés de Lafont ?
Il s'occupe des équipes qui rackettent
les établissements de plaisirs,
de Pigalle et de Montmartre.
Auguste Ricord passe par l'Espagne
et rejoint l'Amérique latine où,
grâce à ses connexions dans le milieu corse,
lui-même est corso-marseillais,
il va devenir un élément central ou en tout cas
l'une des têtes d'affiche de la French Connection,
de cet ensemble de réseaux
qu'on a appelé la French Connection,
qu'on appelle de plus en plus
la Corsican Connection.
Ce sont des accusations
fausses et sans preuves.
Et une accusation sans preuves,
elle peut être niée sans preuve.
Je suis arrivé à la fin de la guerre
en Argentine où aussitôt,
j'ai commencé à faire des restaurants français.
Il n'y en avait pas.
La seule chose qu'on peut me reprocher, c'est
d'avoir eu une clientèle de trafiquants de d****.
Vous avez été condamné en France ?
J'ai été condamné très jeune.
J'avais quatorze ans et demi.
J'ai été condamné pour port d'armes,
et tentative de meurtre.
Par ailleurs, d'autres anciens gestapistes
vont très bien savoir se recycler.
Pierre Loutrel, dit Pierrot le fou,
va fonder après-guerre, au lendemain
immédiat de la guerre,
jusqu'en 45-46, ce qu'on appelait
le gang des tractions avant,
multipliant les braquages, les attaques
à main armée de façon très audacieuse,
ils sont d'ailleurs rentrés dans la légende.
Et qui est dans son équipe ?
Ses proches, ses amis,
On retrouve Jo Attia qui va devenir l'un des
caïds de Paris jusqu'à la fin des années 50,
début des années 60, on retrouve
Abel Danos,  le fameux mammouth,
on retrouve aussi Georges Boucheseiche, qui
va être un voyou d'une extrême importance,
dans les années 60. On retrouve
d'une manière générale,
un certain nombre d'anciens,
peut-être pas directement gestapistes,
mais des gens qui étaient
très proches de cette structure,
qui ont donné des coups de main.
On les retrouvera dans quasiment toutes les
associations criminelles de l'après-guerre.
Fuyant le peloton d'exécution,
la plupart des truands de la Gestapo
française se dispersent dans la nature.
On les retrouve en Europe, en Asie,
en Afrique ou encore aux Amériques.
Cet éparpillement jette les bases
d'organisation internationale du crime.
Cigarettes, d****, armes, pr****.
Ils sont dans tous les trafics,
se mêlant de renseignements,
se rapprochant dangereusement
du monde politique.
Ils interviennent partout.
Si les meneurs ont été mis
hors d'état de nuire en 1944,
nombreux sont les prétendants
prêts à prendre la relève.
Beaucoup de ceux-là sont passés
par la rue Lauriston.
À l'école d'Henri Lafont,
le parrain de la Gestapo.